Haase compressed but his peep and
welcome to freshman yes today you and I
are gonna draw together it's gonna be
amazing so I'm gonna invite you bros
randomly via Twitter for a private
drawing session I'm gonna tell you what
to draw and hopefully it'll begin let's
do this this is the picture we're gonna
draw Oh someone is helping me I don't
know who is strong with me but that's a
nice neck okay that looks yes that looks
great the [ __ ] am I looking at I just
realized more and more how shitty of an
idea this was kill me kill me please oh
thanks they did lead to the whole thing
and now you're restarting it no do
continue stop deleting it you [ __ ]
morons okay so someone joined me and
there there you go that's it
that looks that's my neck thank you for
that appreciate that one I guess I can
draw the outline here yes it looks just
like the original
don't forget the stub stubble yes that's
a nice nose the other person is like
he's [ __ ] ruining my drawing gotta
get that launched Swedish hair yes
drugs flowers this yes I want to see the
person draw my my eyes and stuff like I
don't want to be the one doing this okay
here we go
that looks so good if that I look just
like that after a really long night out
yes
the pupils very big yes oh my god oh
wait someone else finally joined Jesus
Christ like a one eyes I extra intense
like 10 out of 10 10 out of 16
apparently ah pretty damn hot not gonna
lie
let's move on to the next drawing god
damn it why am i so lonely just want to
draw with someone I'm doing the [ __ ]
outline all by myself I guess didn't
think it would be this hard to find
someone to draw with
okay finally people join [ __ ] hell
okay yes
Oh Gabby join Gabby's actually a really
good artist this should be interesting
yeah you really captured that this
stupidness in the eyes that's the most
important part a man no why did you do
that no [ __ ] trolls allowed gotta get
that orange in his eyes right there you
go
nailed in then you got to get that anime
effect yes
now don't [ __ ] ruin it Jesus Christ
oh this is beautiful
did everyone just give up and that
attempt so cute
wait who the [ __ ] said three point five
out of ten
[ __ ] you okay so next up we're gonna
draw a picture of Marzia so that's the
arm it looks like I'll have to take the
lead
yes that's a great face Thank You Nora
oh it just gets better you guys are
artists that's sound out let me help you
out a little bit with the hair oh it's
too good oh is that the mouth I don't
know if I like you you guys doing this
to my girlfriend what the [ __ ] is that
the NIP box what are you doing
don't draw my girlfriend's nipples man
that's that's [ __ ] weird that looks
like the belly oh what happened what
happened what is that what are you doing
I was supplying it over those two
pineapples okay
you
oh my god what the [ __ ] happened
stop you got you bros need to learn when
to stop
alright next up we're gonna draw this
duck Liuba TV wants to join okay no what
are you doing your support this is too
big no no what are you doing stop what
[ __ ] yeah ha ha ha ha draw then draw
then [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is that
what is that that is a great looking
duck havelis
can't stop laughing it's just so fun oh
it's just me laughing like an idiot I'm
sorry it's just so funny ah okay so next
up we're gonna draw this image why does
he look dead this is probably the ugly
like what happened to the chin what is
that oh my god what am i doing
puking rainbows yes IGN ten hundred and
ten out of ten
uh yes oh we forgot his Jewish little
awkward hair sticking out and these
eyebrows are a lot bigger than that
excuse me hahahaha yes now we're talking
so for this one we're gonna draw this
potato okay here we go
the [ __ ] are you doing drawing a potato
on the potato what is this it's at the
face oh no it doesn't look angry god
damn it what the [ __ ] are you all do
drawing different potat you can't just
you can't just potato potatoes yes
draw the dots draw the [ __ ] dots
yes now this is a potato I've never seen
a potato show eager to kill himself look
at their [ __ ] [ __ ] set bro dill oh
okay
haha what who drew a penis that wasn't
me
what the [ __ ] is this God you know what
you guys are failed
all right breasts I had so much fun
drawing with you this was [ __ ] weird
but I love interacting with you brothers
and it's so much fun you're equally
weird as me and I think that's a great
thing so leave a like if you want more
videos like this one and thank you so
much for watching and as always brauch
stay awesome you want to dance you want
a dish
you look like an Australian slight
racism there appreciate it